THANKS FOR JOINING US.
GLOBAL BAGS UNITE.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
>> THE NATIONAL AVERAGE FOR
A GALLON OF GAS HAS GONE UP 10
DAYS IN A ROW AND WE SET A NEW
RECORD.
MOST ANALYSTS EXPECT PRICES TO
KEEP CLIMBING.
ONE ANALYST SAID A NATIONAL
AVERAGE OF $6 A GALLON IS
POSSIBLE.
>> Laura: TO MAKE A BAD
SITUATION WORSE, WE MAY BE
FACING A SHORTAGE OF TRUCKERS
SOON.
THE OWNERS ARE FACING A CRISIS
DUE TO THE SKY ROCKETING COST OF
DIESEL FUEL.
AND FOOD PRICES?
BLOOMBERG HEADLINES CAUGHT MY
EYE.
CHICKEN WINGS FOR $34.
CONSUMER PRICES OF FOOD WERE UP
9.4% IN APRIL COMPARED TO LAST
APRIL.
IT'S THE BIGGEST GAIN SINCE
1981.
IT'S TIME TO ASK THIS QUESTION:
BOTH A GLOBAL AND NATIONAL
LEVEL, IS THE ECONOMIC CHAOS
UNFOLDING BEFORE OUR EYES THE
RESULT OF INCOMPETENCE OR
CAREFUL PLANNING?
TED CRUZ BELIEVES THIS IS ALL
PURPOSESFUL.
>> JOE BIDEN BELIEVES IN GAS IS
$6 OR $10 A GALLON, IF HE
IMPOSES ENOUGH PAIN THAT
EVENTUALLY EVERYONE WILL HAVE
THIS EPIPHANY AND GET RID OF
THAT TRUCK OR MINI-VAN AND
EVERYONE WILL BUY AN ELECTRIC
CAR.
>> Laura: THE "ANGLE" DID NOT
DISAGREE.
BIDEN IS IGNORANT AND HIS
CABINET IS UNQUALIFIED.
BUT THIS CAN'T BE AN ACCIDENT.
NONE OF THIS WAS PREDESTINED.
THE BIDEN TEAM CHOSE TO CANCEL
OIL LEASES, TO STOP KEYSTONE AND
GREN LIT A PROXY WAR AGAINST
RUSSIA.
SENT BILLION DOLLARS TO UKRAINE.
AND PAID PEOPLE NOT TO WORK OVER
AFTER VACCINES WERE AVAILABLE
AND BAILED OUT THE BLUE STATES
THAT REFUSED TO OPEN.
THEY ALLOWED MILLIONS OF
MIGRANTS.
TO THIS DAY THEY REFUSE TO STOP
SCARING AMERICANS ABOUT COVID.
FOR GOOD MEASURE THEY ARE
THREATENING FREE SPEECH.
HATE SPEECH IS ANYTHING THEY
DISAGREE WITH.
THESE POLICIES ARE ALL DESIGNED
TO MAKE YOU POORER AND MAKE YOU
MORE DEPENDENT ON THE
GOVERNMENT.
FORCE YOU TO STOP DRIVING.
STOP ATTENDING SCHOOL BOARD
MEETINGS AND STOP POSTING YOUR
VIEWS ONLINE.
IT'S  GEARED TO LIMIT YOUR
EXPECTATIONS.
AMERICA HAS NO RIGHT TO BE FREER
THAN AFRICA OR EUROPE.
CANDIDATE BARACK OBAMA WAS
EXPLICIT ABOUT THE AMERICAN
RESET IN 2008.
>> WE CAN'T DRIVE OUR SUVS AND
EAT AS MUCH AS WE WANT AND KEEP
OUR HOMES AT FOO DEGREES AT ALL
TIMES AND EXPECT THAT EVERY
OTHER COUNTRY WILL SAY OKAY.
>> Laura: I KNOW WHAT YOU ARE
THINKING.
BLEEP OTHER COUNTRIES!
THAT'S MY REACTION FROM 14
YEARS.
THEY ARE QUICK TO DOWN PLAY THE
IDEA OF AMERICAN GREATNESS.
>> I SUSPECT THAT BRITS BELIEVE
IN BRIT EXCEPTIONALISM.
>> Laura: WE ARE NO MORE
EXCEPTIONAL THAN ANY OTHER
COUNTRY.
HIS ENERGY SECRETARY SLIPPED ON
THE ISSUE OF GASOLINE PRICES TO
THE WALL STREET.
-- "WALL STREET JOURNAL."
WE HAVE TO BOOST PRICES TO THOSE
OF EUROPE.
THEY ALWAYS LIKED EUROPE BETTER
THAN THE UNITED STATES.
WE EMBARRASS THEM ESPECIALLY AT
FANCY GLOBAL CONFERENCES.
AMERICANS REALLY EMBARRASS THEM.
THE RICH AND POWERFUL FROM BIG
GOVERNMENT, BIG TECH AND BIG
PHARMA ARE DESCENDING ON
A MOUNTAIN TOWN IN SWITZERLAND.
THEIR MOTTO IS COMMITTED TO
IMPROVING THE STATE OF THE
WORLD.
ARRIVING ON PRIVATE JET THEY
PLAN THEIR BIG IDEAS TO TACKLE
BIG PROBLEMS.
>> WE ARE WILLING TO CONTINUE
OUR ISSUES IN RELATION TO
CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> TO ADDRESS THE DEEP ROOTED
INEQUALITIES IN THE LABOR
MARKET.
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> WE ESTABLISH TESTS IN OUR
ABILITY TO SHAPE OUR COMMON
FUTURE IN CONSTRUCTIVE WAYS.
>> Laura: THAT LAST MAN IS THE
MAN IN CHARGE AT DAVOS AND
PUSHED THE GLOBAL RESET OF
CAPITALISM WHEN THE BIDEN FOLKS
ARE ON BOARD WITH, BUT THEY CALL
IT SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
>> A NEW NORMAL.
WEARING A MASK.
WORKS IN SHIFTS.
>> WE HAVE TO DESIGN A NEW
NORMAL.
>> I HOPE THE NEW NORMAL WILL
ALSO INCLUDE A REAL STRONG
CORPORATE MEMORY OF WHAT
A PANDEMIC CAN DO.
SO WE DON'T JUST GO ON WHEN WE
GET THIS UNDER CONTROL.
>> Laura: THAT WAS DR. FAUCI
EARLIER THIS YEAR.
THIS YEAR'S THEME IS HISTORY AT
A TURNING POINT.
WITH THE GOAL OF REBUILDING
TRUSTS THROUGH AGREEMENTS
CRUCIAL TO A GLOBAL RECOVERY.
FOLKS LIKE JOHN KERRY AND AL
GORE WILL SIT ON PANELS TALKING
ABOUT ALL OF THE WAYS THEY
SHOULD GIVE WAY TO GLOBALISM.
THE ATTENDEES ARE WELL-HEELED.
MANY ARE BILLIONAIRES.
THEY MAY FEEL LESS ICKY ABOUT
HOW THEY GOT THERE THEY MADE
THEIR MONEY BY GOING THERE.
THIS COMEDIAN HAD AN INTERESTING
TAKE ON THIS.
>> DON'T INVITE THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE [BLEEP] RESPONSIBLE FOR
RUINING IT IN THE FIRST PLACE.
>> Laura: HE IS RIGHT ABOUT ONE
THING.
HISTORY IS AT A TURNING POINT.
GLOBALIZATION IS SLOWING ITS
OUTCOME.
CHINA IS GETTING RICHER.
WE ARE GETTING POORER, THE
SUPPLY CHAIN IS BROKEN.
FROM LOCKDOWNS TO VACCINE
MANDATES, THE PEOPLE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THAT THEY SHOULD PUT IN
JAIL.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WE WERE
SUPPOSED TO TRUST BUT THEY WERE
JUST POLITICAL HACKS ALL ALONG.
TOP GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS ARE NOT
ON TEAM USA.
LIKE JANET YELLEN WHO WAS A FED
CHAIR.
SHE DENIED THAT INFLATION
WITHDRAW COMING AND WANTS TO USE
HER FAILURE AS AN EXCUSE TO LIFT
TARIFFS ON CHINA.
WE ARE AT A TURNING POINT.
WE WILL EITHER REMAIN A FREE AND
INDEPENDENT AMERICA OR WE WILL
SPEND THE NEXT FEW DECADES BEING
PUSHED AROUND AND LOCKED DOWN
AND ORDERED AROUND BY PEOPLE YOU
WOULD NOT TRUST TO IT MOW YOUR
LAWN.
THEY OFFER NOTHING BUT MISERY
AND SCARCITY.
JIMMY CARTER TOOK THAT SAME
PLATFORM IN 1980 AND LOST.
NOW ALL OF THOSE YEARS LATER IN
2022, THE DEMOCRATS AND THE
GLOBALISTS ARE TRYING TO
CONVINCE THAT MORE GOVERNMENT
CONTROL AND LESS FREEDOM IS
A GOOD THING FOR U